- [Voiceover] Yo.
(applause)
- Thank you guys, I appreciate it.
Thanks for being here.
I'm gonna do a quick
survey of how many people
know me and don't know me.
Based on that I will speed up the process
of what we're really here to do,
which is straight up Q and
A in your fuckin' mouth.
And so the mic is in the
middle of the aisle now.
You're more than welcome
to start getting up
if you've got a question
and getting in line
because I'd like to
start answering question
as soon as possible.
But before we get to that part,
I'd like to get a sense of how many
people do know my backstory
cause then I'll set up the
context for this Q and A.
I'm also feeling a little bit awkward.
I'm stunned that nobody's
gotten in line yet.
(laughter)
How many people in this audience
actually really don't know who
I am or don't know my spiel?
Please raise your hand.
Alright, this dude didn't
know me so well he stood up.
I get it dude, fuck.
OK, so I'm gonna give a
little context, not too much
cause first of all I'm humbled
by how many of you know.
I'm an entrepreneur.
I'm a immigrant, I was born
in the former Soviet Union.
I came to the US as a
young guy, three years old.
My parents hustled and
worked their faces off
to give us a middle class life.
My dad eventually owned a liquor store
in Clark, New Jersey and then Springfield.
Big ups to Jersey, yes,
there's seven of us,
let's hold it down.
And I grew up real lemonade
stand, baseball card kid,
real kinda hustler kid, shit student.
Punted school around fourth grade
when I got my first F on a test
and just decided I was
gonna be a businessman.
Got involved in my dad's
liquor store business
as a 14 year old.
Hated it.
By the time I was 17 I
realized people collected wine
and that kind of brought
me into that ecosystem.
Discovered the Internet when I was 18.
At that point spent 20
minutes in my entire life
when I was 18 years old
on a computer, ever.
So clearly, very different
that the youngsters in here.
Realized that this Internet
thing was something real.
Decided that I was going to launch
a very early e-commerce business.
And in 1996 I launched one
of the first e-commerce
wine businesses in America.
From 1998 to 2005,
in that five to seven year,
2003 to 2005 that kind of range,
I grew my dad's business from
a 3 to a 65 million dollar
a year wine e-commerce
and bricks and mortar store.
At that point, after
actually building a business,
I thought it was,
a opportunity for me to talk
about those kind of things.
It first started, ironically,
with me believing that
this new thing, YouTube,
was gonna be big
and so I started a wine show on YouTube
that popped and created Wine Library TV.
Anybody here ever watch Wine Library TV?
(small applause)
Appreciate it, thanks mom.
And that went extremely well,
that led to me understanding
that the Internet was changing.
the one that I grew up with.
And decided that I wanted
to go all in on that world.
It was actually South by Southwest, 2008,
a year after Twitter popped
that I kind of came here.
Really felt the energy, felt
like the world was shifting.
Felt the Internet was going into a very,
very mainstream place and
decided to focus on it.
A couple months later,
while actually meeting Blaine Cook,
the original CTO of Twitter here,
I invested in Twitter.
I went on to invest in
Facebook and Tumblr
in that 2008, 2009 period.
That went extremely well.
I wrote a book called Crush It!
It's good to see Stephanie
Land in the audience.
She's my, Stephie, you
know what, stand up.
Stand up Steph.
This is my ghost writer that
I reference all the time.
Let's here it for Steph.
There'd be no books without her.
(applause)
That's not a good enough clap.
Imagine dealing with me.
My absolute partner in
crime in that world.
And so, actually we wrote
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook
on the floor at South by
Southwest, for like six hours.
Anyway, so this has been a
very special place for me.
I stumbled into kind of a
tradition that I ended last year,
which was a secret wine party.
I used to ship wine down here
and then pick a random
bar and then tweet at it
and we'll have like a Twitter storm.
It's a very special place.
I'm really excited to be here
again with all of you guys.
What I'm here to do is do Q and A.
Somewhere along my career
after Crush It! came out,
after my brother AJ and
I started VaynerMedia
which is a social digital shop.
I started doing more
and more public speaking
and what I realized somewhere
around 2012, 13, 14,
was the Q and A part of my talk was where
very honestly, selfishly, I
was able to separate myself.
You know, if general, I
don't do, as you can tell,
slides, things of that
nature so that was good,
I had a speaking style.
I would context the room,
this is gonna be a very different talk
that lets say if this was
Fortune 500 executives.
You know, I was doing my thing
but it was the Q and A part where people
realized that I was a practitioner.
I'm very proud to not be a
pundit or a social commentator
or a guru or a thought leader.
I'm proud to be a practitioner.
I'm proud that I've now
built two businesses.
You know, Wine Library I built
in five years, from 3 to 65.
VaynerMedia I built from 3
to 100 million in four years.
There are real businesses, right.
And these are not
businesses of selling people
on how to make money.
This is not guru shit, this
is real fuckin' business.
And I take a lot of pride in that.
And in the Q and A sessions is when
I've been able to establish that.
So I got selfish 18 months ago.
A young man by the name
of DRock came into my life
and we started making videos
and we started the #AskGaryVee Show
which has been very,
very successful for me.
I really enjoy it.
I've really reconnected with a lot of you
because I've been down, kind of head down
for two or three years building Vayner
in between Wine Library TV
and the #AskGaryVee Show
and so it's been fun to kinda get back
into the world with you guys.
I'm enjoying the format.
I decided to write a book about it
because very honestly,
the entire KPI for this whole execution
this last few years is
to allow me to come here,
talk for five minutes, seven minutes,
create a little context
for those that don't know
and really do what we're about to do.
Because I think it's
the biggest value prop.
You're more than welcome
to go to this website,
it's called Youtube.
There's a fuckload of
videos that could show you
exactly what I could do
here for the next hour
but what we can do with Q and A
is actually get into the details.
So with that,
I would like to go into it.
So thank you, guys for coming.
Let's clap it up for each other.
(applause)
You're up my man.
- [Voiceover] Alright, hi.
- Tell everybody who
you are and what you do.
- [Voiceover] So I'm Garry
Polmateer, @DarthGarry,
with two R's.
- I know brother.
- [Voiceover] I work at Red Argyle
and do Salesforce.com stuff.
- Great.
- [Voiceover] So the first
time I hear the word empathy
in a business context it was from you.
- OK.
- [Voiceover] And it really such a big
thought process change for me, like,
I'm not, we're not just machines
that go through the day to day.
We're really trying to
make something happen
and have these connection.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] My thought is,
when did that word enter your vocabulary
and how did you start systematically
applying it to your relationships?
- I was systematically
applying it my whole life.
I mean, I think I'm one
of the great salespeople,
I really believe that.
I have ego along with my empathy.
(laughter)
I think it's completely
because of empathy.
Right, Garry.
Like I know you, we
interact, I know that we met
at that SalesForce conference.
Like that's where we
started really talking.
Like, and why?
Yes, I'm caring, but I
understand that people,
if they care about
somebody else in return,
enjoy those things.
Like saying thank you for everybody
that was walking in right now.
That's important.
Like, it's an important
process where I, you know,
it's funny.
I actually often think am I
using empathy as a good thing
or even as a bad thing.
I recognize it's power.
Like somebody acknowledging,
just saying a hello,
like actually giving
a fuck is a real thing
and most importantly,
if you understand what the
other person is thinking
and you are a true salesperson,
an operator and business person,
you can reverse engineer it to get
what you need to get
out of the relationship.
If I understand what the
KPI is on the other side,
I can reverse it and I
think the best salespeople
in the world actually know
the game that's being played
when nobody's actually saying it.
In corporate America, 95% of the things
that are coming out of
the mouth of my clients,
is not what really is going on.
And so, empathy has allowed
me to figure out what
they're really trying to do.
Are they trying to use my ability to see
where things are going or be current,
to get headlines for them
so they can get a promotion
in their organization.
You need to know these things, right.
And you also use them to understand
when somebody's down
you need to help, right.
So empathy I think is
something I've always deployed.
I've always, you know,
I see it in my kids, right.
My wife is empathetic and
I see both my kids already,
they're in a playground,
they're four years old,
a kid falls, scrapes their knee.
And they stop what they're
doing and they come over.
That's not, you're not instilling that.
That's a DNA trait.
You're empathetic to somebody else
and I think that empathy and
gratitude and self awareness.
And that's why in this new book,
I went much more EQ than
I have historically,
cause I'm ready, at this point in my life,
to start opening up on the things
that I don't know how to teach.
I know how to tactically
tell you to buy filters
on Snapchat right now
cause they're underpriced
for you know, the awareness
of what I think they bring
to the table and you
can use them to capture
a little bit of brand
equity that will go away
once everybody does it
in four to seven months.
I can tactically tell you that.
I haven't figured out how to
teach you to be self aware.
teach you to be empathetic
but I wanna bring the conversation
to entrepreneurs and startup
land because it's real
and if you're an actual operator,
when you go through 20 to 640 employees
in 48 months like I just have,
it's only the EQ that allows
that culture to survive.
It's not, it's not the
two week vacation policy,
it's not all this horseshit.
It's the human part and nobody's
talking about that enough.
That looks like me, right.
I don't look like the
person that's gonna be
the Mother Theresa,
warm feelings, like right.
I don't project that here
when the lights are on.
When I wanna rip your faces off.
But back home, one on one, I do.
That's how you build organizations.
It matters extremely, matters internally
and it actually matters
enormously externally.
Because if you're empathetic to what,
why the person doesn't want
to buy your SaaS product.
If you actually understood,
if you understood there was enough people
thinking the same thing,
you'd adjust the product.
Thanks Garry.
- [Voiceover] Thanks so much.
- You should drop one of your R's.
Hello.
- [Voiceover] Hey Gary.
My name's Kathy Gardner
and I work at Team Detroit
as a social strategist
specializing in Youtube.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] I'm a big
fan of the #AskGaryVee Show,
I've watched it since the very beginning.
- Thank you so much.
- [Voiceover] I'm please
to be speaking with you.
- Thank you.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, so you
often say that marketers
ruin everything when it comes
to joining social platforms
and I tend to agree with that.
- Or anything that has the
consumers attention, right.
We've ruined earth, we
put billboards up, right.
Like any, where ever we think
there's eyes and ears, we will ruin that.
Video games, all of the
sudden have Sprite like in it.
Like we ruin everything.
- [Voiceover] So how do
you work to avoid that
with your clients at VaynerMedia?
- We don't.
We try to ruin.
Ruin is the slang term for being smart
and day trading attention.
Ruin means, in my world, good things.
Which is, everyone's like
Gary, I wanna be cool
on Snapchat as a business.
I'm like, why?
You're a business, you wanna
sell shit on Snapchat, right.
Now if cool is a byproduct of doing that,
then that's fine but I
use it tongue-in-cheek
when I say ruin it.
I think the people that best ruin it
are people that do things
that actually work.
I think I'm great at
ruining things, right.
When I say ruining I
mean we take a pure thing
that is supposed to be,
Twitter, it's supposed
to just be communication
that's gonna change the world.
And I went there a sold a
fuckload of wine and books
and all sorts of shit on it,
but I didn't do it in a
way that made people upset.
I did it in a way where I
brought the biggest value.
I ironically, think the best pure,
pure in utter form of a
marketer and a salesperson
is an amazing person.
Do you know why I think
I'm an amazing salesman?
Because I really believe
with my entire heart and soul
in everything I sell
and I know that 90% of the
sales people in this room don't.
Right?
They make their money
because this SEO is still
where they're in, right.
They make their money in
YouTube preroll cause that is.
But I know deep down in
their heart they know,
that they don't consume that,
that they don't believe in that.
And that's what puts
me in a very good place
and so when I say ruin I mean,
even as a collective,
there's too many people
doing it the wrong way and
they're gonna fuck it up.
As a collective there's
gonna be 800,000 shitty
Snapchat filters that come
out over the next seven months
and that over time will make it less cool
for all of us as a normal person, right.
But the people that do it best win.
It's always gonna happen.
Not me, not you, not the
collective, not the industry,
nobody's gonna stop advertising
to happen in places where people are.
I just wanna show people that
there's a better way to do it
and it starts by not
stealing people's time.
You know it starts with that,
that's why I don't like
YouTube prerolls as much.
That's why I don't like
television commercials.
That's why I don't like banner
fuckin' ads in my iPhone.
Like, don't take my time,
that's an asset to me.
And so, that's why the native movement
or anything that can
remotely look like that.
To really answer your question,
the people that can create
the least amount of friction
by still promoting their product win.
That's why I think product
placement in movies and television
is going to be a much bigger business
over the next 20, 30 years
cause it's a good way to integrate
without stopping you from watching
what you want or stealing your time.
- [Voiceover] Thank you.
Excited for the book.
- Thank you so much.
Big ups to the guy in the
eighth row wearing the Jets hat.
It's making me feel really good, bro.
What's up man?
- [Voiceover] Hey, this is
Johnathan Van from Technium.
We invest in deep science technologies
coming out of universities
but this is actually from the girlfriend,
she's a TV reporter out in Nebraska.
She wants to know, as a TV reporter,
how you, where would you post
to give value to your audience.
They already post on Facebook.
They started their Snapchat feed.
Like what else, how do you
gather your news and where do
you see news going if you
were to run a newsroom?
- So news is being
democratized and curated
in equal directions at the same time.
So I think where they post is
kind of weirdly irrelevant.
Do they understand the context
of the platform when they post?
That's the key.
The biggest problem isn't content,
it's that people don't understand
the context of the room they're in
and thus the content never had a chance
because they lacked the self awareness.
They lacked the empathy
for what's going on there.
You can't put a TV spot on Snapchat
and think it's gonna work.
It feels out of place.
It's like the 57 year old dude in a suit
that comes to like a
hipster party in Brooklyn
that has all 18 and 22 year olds.
Like you're out of fuckin'
place bro, you know.
And so, I think the answer to
your question's quite simple.
News will always like
widen and contract, right.
There's plenty of people
that curate, you know.
I get my news from Nuzzel, right,
which is like, that's where I get it.
Or at my stream when
I'm listening to people,
you know like I found out
about Matt Forte singing with
the Jets from the 7000
people that tweeted at me
in the second that it happened
and said, what do ya think?
I'm like, I think it's awesome by the way.
And so, I think for them,
in the cliche, middle America newsroom,
they're usually, you
know I'm generalizing,
out of touch with what their audience
wants in those mediums.
And they're doing TV in social
and I think that's a mistake.
And so I would tell her,
for her own brand first and foremost
and then for the
organization she works for,
to start really relying on context.
Understand what's really
happening in there.
- [Voiceover] Thank you.
- You got it.
- [Voiceover] HI, my name is Alan.
- Alan.
- [Voiceover] I do
publishing on the Instagram,
Twitter and Snapchat
but basically my question is
on weed start ups.
- Weed.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, weed,
marijuana, cannabis.
- I heard it.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] OK, there is a
company called Get Meadow
backed by Ycombinator
they're calling it the uber for weed.
- Everybody's calling everything
the uber of everything.
I'm the uber of humans, bitch.
Go ahead.
- [Voiceover] The uber of
weed is actually very cool
because you can like type in your zip code
and then live conference with a doctor
that'll get you a card and all that stuff.
- OK.
- [Voiceover] But I
live in Houston, right,
so that's illegal for me.
- Good.
- [Voiceover] So it doesn't work right.
- OK.
- [Voiceover] Now the other
dude before you started
talking about.
- Steve?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, the rise of the rest
and everyone having the opportunity.
So what about people who are
like selling, who wanna.
OK, I feel like drug dealers
are entrepreneurs of.
- Like the purest form.
(laughter)
No, seriously, like, like.
- [Voiceover] OK, so my question is,
if somebody who was
born into wealth, right.
- Yep.
- [Voiceover] They live in
Silicon Valley, that's cool.
- Yep.
- [Voiceover] They can either
get $150,000 license a year.
- Don't get it twisted man.
Stop your hate real quick.
Most people that get
money from Silicon Valley
don't come from fuckin' Silicon Valley.
So stop it right there.
But keep goin', but I'm not
gonna just let you cliche it
cause that's bullshit. It's just not true.
Go ahead.
- [Voiceover] OK, so now, how does,
OK, an entrepreneur like me.
What if I wanted to study cannabis?
- Then move to fuckin' Denver, bitch.
Fuck Houston.
- [Voiceover] Why do I
have to move to Denver?
- Cause that's the current law.
Why do I hate Texas with all my heart?
Because I, yeah, I just did,
I'll tell you exactly
right to your face.
I hate Texas, listen I hate Houston more
than you fuckin' hate the system right now
because I built a wine business
where I ship wine and this
fuckin' bullshit ass state
took spec's money, the politicians,
and blocked only one store
from shipping to Texas,
me cause I was at the top of the heap.
I was doing four million in sales here.
Saving all Texas people money
cause I was creating competition
and the wholesalers, three of them,
paid your fuckin' bullshit
ass Houston politicians
to block me from shipping here.
And one day I got a letter.
It said you can't ship here anymore.
So what am I supposed to do.
I can open a store in
fuckin' Texas and throw down
or I can adjust.
That's what you have to do.
Nobody gives a fuck
about your feelings bro.
(laughter)
No, no but for real, like, like.
And the reason I'm
coming at you like this,
is I'm pumped for you, you're a kid.
Don't cry about, here's
the biggest problem.
Bullshit entrepreneurs cry
about the way they want it to be
instead of reacting to
the way it actually is.
(applause)
So you need to eliminate rich kids,
cause I was born with dick.
I lived in a studio apartment
with eight family members
on the size of this stage
and split toilet paper, OK.
So there's no excuse that somebody.
Most people that are
born with wealth, bro,
they lose, cause they're soft.
So if you're so angry
put it to good energy
and go move to Denver
or enjoy 19 to 22, chill,
then move to Denver
or wait for the laws to change.
You can't cry about how it is.
That's just never, ever,
ever, ever the right move.
(applause)
I would argue that there
was not enough clapping
for that part right there,
and that the collective,
and that the collective energy
of this room is bullshit.
Let's step it up.
(applause)
Fuck.
That was some real shit.
Steve, that was some real shit, Steve.
And they're like, yeah good shit.
That was fuckin' real.
Fuck.
Sorry.
- [Voiceover] We forgive you Gary.
- Thank you darlin', what's cookin'?
- [Voiceover] My name is Maria Falcurin
and I work for Capital
One and I'm a career coach
and speaker on career
strategy in social media.
- Love it.
- [Voiceover] I am a fellow
recovering immigrant.
- Great.
- [Voiceover] Former Soviet Union.
- Amazing.
- [Voiceover] And I have
an utterly unoriginal question for you.
- No worries.
- [Voiceover] Talk to me
about the public speaking.
What is your number one recommendation
for being a powerful, effective, impactful
public speaker who makes a difference?
- 100% of your energy and effort
has to be completely predicated
on what brings value to the audience.
Most public speakers come
up here, and you're gonna see it.
87% of the time at this
South by Southwest,
the people on stage are
doing press releases
for their company to the audience, period.
And so the reason I have a career
is I come here and the only thing,
that was tough love for
a kid that I want to win.
I'm doing this because
I want to bring value.
It's about bringing value.
Way too many people speak
and it's a press release.
And so what's worked for me is
the reason I don't have the same speech
is the same speech doesn't work
for that awesome kid from
Houston the same as it does
for a 59 year old exec CCO, right,
of like an agency.
I have to know the room,
I have to reverse the room
and then I have to basically
deploy the current state
of things for that room.
And that's what I think people have to do.
I'm blown away by how
selfish speakers are.
Blown away, like I'm
stunningly disrespectful
to a lot of the people
that you guys compare me to
because they're up there
slingin' their shit
and promoting themselves and
don't give a fuck about you.
- [Voiceover] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(applause)
- [Voiceover] Hey.
- Hey.
- [Voiceover] Thank you,
very excited to be here.
I'm Sarah Beebee of London.
I want to ask you about
your summer, do you.
(laughter)
- It's that weed, no I'm just kidding.
- [Voiceover] And I love that.
I just wondered as you were
building your companies.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] Can you
expect people to work
at the same level that you work at?
- I'm not even sure if I've
met another human being
that's willing to work
at the level I'm at.
So no, and you can never
expect your employees
to work at the level of the founder
because it's your company and
it's not theirs and to expect.
This is one of my biggest beefs
with a lot of my founder friends.
They're like, oh they're
not working as hard as me.
I'm like you own 94% of
the company, you know.
What the fuck's the matter with you?
Like, I never expect that, keep going.
- [Voiceover] I was
just wondering as you're
building your companies
do you surround yourself
with people, not people not just like you
because that would just
be weird and fucked up.
- Yes, and since they don't exist.
- [Voiceover] They exist,
but you, yeah, how do you?
- Easy, I am worried about
surrounding myself with the following.
First and foremost, good human beings
that understand that
emotional intelligence
trumps IQ in my building
every day of the week.
I can teach you the algorithm
of the Facebook feed of
the current environment.
I can teach you why listening and big data
can help you on Twitter.
I can teach you that,
you know, hashtag culture
within Instagram that makes it work.
I can teach you to pay attention today,
to musical.ly and Anchor!
and Peach and AfterSchool.
I can teach you that.
I can't teach you to not
be a douchbag, you know.
And so, first and foremost, it's EQ.
Second of all, I one by one, one by.
Ben, Benruby.
Emily McDonough, I want Dan Grossman,
I one by one these people
and try to get to know them
and I've spent numerous minutes,
with these three, hours,
to fundamentally understand
what makes them tick.
What do they want?
Dan wants to be a big time DJ, great,
so then I will introduce
him to I don't know, Avicii.
And so like, you know
what I do all the time
is try to understand what
matters to them and it evolves.
When Dan first started working for me,
he wasn't married, right.
So different things mattered.
I'm mentally prepared to reverse engineer
anybody that ever works for me
and understand what makes them tick.
I hate when people are
like, oh millennials.
There's no fuckin' millennials.
There's no millennials.
There's Rick, there's
Carlos, there's Drew.
Like there's people,
and I have millennials
that wanna work their fuckin' faces off
just to make another hundred bucks
cause they love that fuckin' money, right.
And I have millenials who wanna make,
you know the money's fine,
but they'll live in a
studio with 40 people
just so they can go to Coachella
and drink $19 green juice.
Right?
So, and here's the best part.
I don't give a shit.
I don't care how you wanna live.
I definitely don't want
people to live the way I do
because it's super intense
and it's not normal.
- [Voiceover] How do you
stop your crazy energy
from scaring people away?
(laughter)
- No, no, no, listen.
I mean, like, the things
that I can't control
I don't worry about.
If somebody gets scared
and quits VaynerMedia
then they weren't able to
see past the surface level
of this, that, right.
So I'm never scared.
I know what my intent is.
I know what my skill set is.
And so I'm attracting the people
that I want to attrack, right?
And so the people that are leaving
and they've all been here
for two, three, four years.
They know, they have a
pretty amazing track record
of who's still here and who's not
and that's building confidence
and that's building scale
and then, because I can't be everywhere,
you know when somebody's
crying in the girl's bathroom
because this place sucks
because they're middle manager
isn't doing the right thing.
Well then Emily hears that
she can interact with that,
say you should go talk to Gary.
And like I'm the head of HR.
Like, you know, and so I would say that,
that energy thing, I'm sure
some people have been scared
but I'm a little bit, I'm
way more energetic on stage
and when I'm on, than when I'm operating.
When you talk to people that work with me
for three or four years,
they say that I'm overly patient.
Nobody thinks that about me.
You don't think that about me
if you don't know me, right.
Like I'm a big time listener.
Nobody believes that.
I just caught Steph's
face, my ghost writer,
cause she's always been
fun for me to watch
because she knows how my persona is
but she knows how we interact.
She knows what kind of client I am
in a world where she's
got plenty of other people
she ghost writes for and
I have a funny feeling
I'm at the top of her list of likability
even though if we named em all,
it would seem like, oh
no, he must be tough
or too intense or this,
that and the other thing.
So I don't worry about
things I don't control.
I don't expect anybody to be
anything other than themselves.
And then I think I work for them
and I need to put them in
the best position to succeed.
All three of the people I
just mentioned are in very
different positions than
they were 12 months ago.
And all, right now, thank God,
it's probably why I'm saying it,
are in the probably best
spots they've been at Vayner
since they've been there.
They're making the biggest impact
and having the best time.
And we've been through our
trials and tribulations, right.
There's been the dinner
when Dan decided, OK,
he's not a douchbag,
he's a good guy, right.
Like that's real.
That's how.
- [Voiceover] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(applause)
And this is why I want to
build a massive business.
Because I wanna teach the
world that you can build
a billion dollar empire on good.
(applause)
Like there's no reason.
This unfortunate narrative that
affected a lot of my friends
of Steve Jobs, like it
became the move to be a dick
because you're gonna get
the best work out of people.
Listen, I'm not Steve, you know I'm me.
I'll tell you right now, I'm 40.
So far here's what I got for you.
People work way better when
you deploy honey than vinegar.
Like you can get the
best work out of people.
I got much better work out of people
because they're guilted to let me down
versus being scared of me.
Get the fuck out of here.
My man.
- [Voiceover] Gary.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] Thank you for being here.
- Thank you, what's your name?
- [Voiceover] Gary Yorimo
from Baton Rouge even though
my badge says Bacon Rouge.
(laughter)
I'm loving DailyVee, I wanna give out.
- Dude, let's go back to
this Bacon Rouge thing.
I think there's something here.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] I'm telling you
it's very good in Louisiana
but D-Roc, I wanna give
a big shout out to DRock
for making this.
- Let's hear it up for DRock.
(applause)
DRock-a-fella.
He's gettin' fancy in private last night.
- [Voiceover] An operator,
Paul Shoal, work hard.
But I would love to hear
what you have to say
when you measure your personal growth
and your business growth.
How do you know
with YouTube coming out
or a VaynerMedia or your phone
that you're growing and you say,
I'm taking a hard knock?
- From a individual
like growth perspective.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, both,
like you, everything.
- The business is easy,
right, like I'm just talking
to my book people like we've
sold a fuckload more of these
that the last one so they're happy.
So like that's easy, we're winning.
The personal part, is,
I'm in a funny spot with
personal growth man.
Like I've been
pretty happy and pretty content
with where I am mentally
for a very long time.
I fully believe that I was gifted to see
the positive in everything.
The reason I have good culture
is I suffocate under
negativity, I can't breath.
And so you know it's just a
byproduct of my own thing.
I'm always growing,
we're all always growing.
I'm a better version of myself.
I can feel it even on this tour.
I've never gotten feedback like this.
Like it's unbelievable how many people
the 92nd Street Y talk that I gave,
which I'm getting a lot of feedback from.
You know, everyone's like,
oh you're really growing.
Yeah, I'm getting older, like it changes.
You wanna talk about different things.
I'm starting to understand unveil
more of the stuff that
really makes me successful
which is way more the EQ stuff.
But target to be successful.
- [Voiceover] That was one of the things.
- I don't think it has to.
I think it could be a benefit.
You know I think people
found out about Zappos
through Tony Hsieh's you know
early social media stuff.
So you know I think the
mistake is a personal brand.
Look, there's way more businesses
that we don't know the CEO of
where they're dominating and
she's not out there promoting.
There's some people that are like me
and then of course I get those questions
but it is not a cost of
entry to be successful
in 2020 in 2030 to be out there
for your business to be successful.
Just go and build the best.
VaynerMedia's winning
because we're the best
social digital agency in the land.
Not because of me.
We're winning because all our business,
if you look at my business right now,
the hundred million revenue,
60 or 70 of it is because
people went to other companies
and hired Vayner or told
their friends to hire Vayner
because the work was good.
I don't work on any account, goose egg.
Robert Parrish, double fuckin' zero.
That's how many accounts I work on.
So I don't think you
have to be at the front.
Retail needs to worry about to happen over
the next 20, 30 years which
is every person in this room
is going to get product
delivered to them within an hour.
And in that world, they
don't need Best Buy.
They don't even need Amazon.
The products you sell at Best Buy
are going to sell to consumers
direct in their home on one hour delivery.
That's what they need to worry about.
- [Voiceover] Cool.
- Cool.
- [Voiceover] Thanks.
- Thanks brother.
(applause)
- [Voiceover] Hi, I'm Katie Costello.
Super excited to be here.
I'm originally from Buffalo,
go Bills, the division.
- Pfffffffft.
- [Voiceover] Love hate relationship.
- There's no love part
of that relationship,
just so you know.
- [Voiceover] As you know
we're gonna win the Superbowl
this year.
(laughter)
Everywhere you go there's,
there's always a Bill's
fan everywhere you go
but anyways, that aside,
I now live in Chicago.
I work at a company
called Creative Circle.
We're a specialized staffing
agency in all the major markets
for digital creative things.
- Know it, yep.
- [Voiceover] So, but
my question for you is.
- Can you name the Buffalo
Bill's offensive line?
Good, keep going.
- [Voiceover] Yeah,
honest, straight shooter.
- Love it, go ahead.
- [Voiceover] So my question for you is
I know that you are really good at kind of
predicting a trend,
you're very successful.
That you can kind of foresee
what's gonna be next.
- Be careful Katie, I
know we interact a lot.
You've heard this from
me, I don't think that.
I think I just move
fast when it's obvious.
- [Voiceover] I think you've
got a good pulse on it.
- I think I'm willing
to fuckin' work, right.
Like I think I'm willing to
stay up from one to three
even though I'm busy as shit,
and play with musical.ly when
it's obviously in the top 25
of the free apps store
for months at a time
and I'm baffled that people in this room
don't know what it is.
- [Voiceover] I would agree with that.
- Cool, keep going.
- [Voiceover] My question for you is,
with certain things that I
know, OK, you know you saw this.
You kind of had an inkling
like for so long you've been
saying Snapchat gonna
be really good profits
and one of the top two.
- Yes, yes.
- [Voiceover] When was the last time
when you kind of thought that
you maybe had that
intuition about something
and you were wrong?
- Never on the macrothesis,
but wrong in my execution
or the company that was gonna pull it off.
So thinking about South by,
I was obsessed with Grindr, right.
(laughter)
I was leaving that for you
guys, that was for you.
I was convinced that what
was going on with Grindr
between gay men was gonna happen between,
you know boys and girls,
right, convinced, convinced.
And so the way, when I
first decided that in 2010
the way I thought that was gonna happen
was through people discovery.
It was gonna be more like let's
meet each other around similar interests,
but what I really knew was
shit was gonna go bow
chicka wow wow, right.
So I was chasing Tinder
for four years, right.
I invested in a company called Yobongo.
I invested in a company called One.
I didn't invest in Highlight
which popped here four years ago
but I wanted to but I didn't feel good
because it was too direct
of a competitor of Yobongo.
But I was convinced it was gonna happen.
I'm so glad that Tinder
was built internally
and nobody could have invested in it
cause I would have been
really sad if I missed it.
It was really the one
thing I was scared of.
I know smart refrigerators are
gonna reorder your product.
I know virtual reality
is gonna be at scale
and is the next Internet for real.
Like the next true platform,
I know it's 20 years away
and everybody thinks it's tomorrow.
But you know, so I'm really
good at consumer behavior.
I just sometimes think things
are a little too early.
Like maybe I'm wrong about
how fast it's gonna happen.
I was pretty wrong about Google Glass.
That's a good one.
- [Voiceover] Does that
like teach you anything
when you're like, OK, I'm wrong?
- No, tell me I'm a fuckin' entrepreneur.
When you're an entrepreneur
you fuckin' lose.
It's like UFC,
there's no fuckin' undefeated
in entrepreneurship.
It taught me how much I love to get,
you know that scene in the
movie, the cliche scene,
where the guy punched in the mouth
and he just goes pffft.
Spits the blood and
looks back at the person.
You're like, oh fuck,
shit's about to go down.
As an entrepreneur that's who I am.
I don't even respect my losses.
I don't give em the time
to teach me anything.
I fuckin' look em in the face and go,
fuck you and I keep going and I mean that.
Way too many of you dwell on your losses.
It's holding you back.
Shit's over, you lost.
Move the fuck on.
- [Voiceover] Interesting
perspective, thank you so much.
- You got it.
(applause)
The energy still blows, fuck you guys.
I wish different people were here.
(laughter)
Just telling the truth.
Go ahead my man.
- [Voiceover] Hi Gary, my name's Jordan.
I'm from New York,
recovering investment banker.
(laughter)
So I'm a Gary V newb's.
I learned about you three days ago
through the James Altucher podcast.
- Yes, I ripped the
shit out of that right.
- [Voiceover] I listened
to it three times.
- Yes, good job.
- [Voiceover] I want to ask
you a question because of
the amount of exposure
you've had to start ups.
- Well clearly not
enough, oh it's a phone.
- [Voiceover] And have succeeded,
what you really look for is it?
- The jockey, the guy, the girl.
The girl or the guy, the jockey.
I only bet on two things.
The space, right now for me, e-sports.
VR, B to B, because I think
B to C's way too far away.
Direct to consumer products
that are fully integrated.
Those are things that pop up,
I'm always looking at social networks,
what's the next Snapchat or things,
Pinterest or things of that nature.
So I've got my thesis, right,
where there are things on the board.
SaaS businesses that
are in boring industries
where they suck at marketing
and I know that my help can
make it go through the roof.
So those kind of, I look for
my thesises and then when I.
VR Sound, I've been looking at it.
I meet all the VR Sound
people, and then I look,
and I'm like she's fuckin' a killer, her.
So that's my process, straight up.
- [Voiceover] So it's a top down process.
Your thesis and then finding?
- Yeah, I mean, but,
back to like if we're talking
like investment banking terms
like we're talking like
more hard core business.
If you roll in and you're in a genre
that I don't fully understand,
but you completely blow me away
in my intuitive radar as an operator,
I will often make a bet on that
because I'll learn alongside
that operator in a space that
I don't know as much about
and I'll make that strategic decision
because my belief is
I'll learn this space.
If he or she loses,
I'm still gonna have a
relationship with them.
I still believe they're
a winner, intuitively.
They can turn out to be
a loser and that happens
and then I don't care.
But if they're a winner I want to be there
for the second and the third.
All those idiots that
didn't invest in Twitter
because they lost money
with Ev in Ideo, you know.
That was nuts, right.
Like that was, he
already won with Blogger.
He was clearly a winner.
You gotta bet on the jockey
more than the horse in this game.
- [Voiceover] OK. Thanks a lot.
- You got it brother.
(applause)
- [Voiceover] Hey Gary,
I'm gonna live post this really quick.
So my question is.
- What's your name bro?
- [Voiceover] Oh sorry, Diego.
- Diego.
- [Voiceover] Nice to meet you man.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Voiceover] Mexico.
- Thank you man.
- [Voiceover] So one of my questions is,
I think that messaging services
are really undertapped,
especially in like developing countries.
- OK.
- [Voiceover] What have
you seen that your clients
are like how.
Are they asking you how can I get into,
like Whatsapp's and hundreds
of millions of users?
How can I get into
Facebooks messenger users?
- Hell yes, yes they are.
- [Voiceover] And what are
they, what's the strategy
to get in there?
- It's a place where I've
been very careful with
with my clients because
I'm very concerned that we,
because of what happened with email
and our texting behavior.
Real, I mean I don't
think a lot of people here
really want BMW to show up
in their messaging apps.
And I think we are all way too confused
by what happened in China with WeChat
and we think it's a foregone conclusion.
We don't factor in America enough
that China is still a communist country.
Like we are, coming from the Soviet Union.
Like there is a stunning misunderstanding
of what happens over there.
Yes it's very capitalistic
in a lot of ways,
but there's no scenario in America
where Zucks gets to go to Barack,
yo B, kill Snapchat, cool.
Like that doesn't happen here.
This is real meritocracy.
And so some of the behaviors
and things that go on in
China, are very unique
to where that's a much
more real conversation.
Got it?
And so if I look at behavior now,
you know we all now
have lived through email
being destroyed by marketing,
marketers ruin everything.
I was a happy, I had an email newsletter
in 1996 that had 91% open rates.
I ruined email.
So like, you know, so
I think it's gonna have
to be very, very smart.
I do not think in between
your and my conversations
about the big football match
that a fuckin' Adidas ad should show up.
And I think that's what
everybody's defaulting into
because 99.9% of people are not clever.
And I think we need to figure
out how to make it work.
And I think it could, but I think there's
dumb ideas right now
of how it's gonna work.
And I think we really don't want it.
- [Voiceover] Thanks.
- You got it.
(applause)
There we go, a little
bit better, thanks David.
(applause)
- [Voiceover] Hi Gary,
I'm Nina from Norway.
- Hey Nina.
- [Voiceover] I'm from Unquote,
I Head of User Engagement.
What do you think is the most interesting
platform right now?
- You mean like an app
or overall platform like?
- [Voiceover] I'm talking
about Instagram, Snapchat.
- Got it.
I think Snapchat.
I think Snapchat's the
most interesting thing
to watch right now because
we're living through the moment
of watching everybody go on it.
That's always the best moment.
Like watching the masses, watching like,
and it's really fun to watch
because it's so different.
If you look at your mobile phone right now
and you look at Instagram,
Facebook, Twitter, Pinterest,
the UI and and UX is the same.
It's a feed, it's a feed as we know it.
Snapchat's the first new language
with completely different context,
plus it's forcing us to be very
creative in a different way.
It's probably what, it's forcing us to do
what I probably thought
Justin TV was gonna do
and UStream with live
streaming years ago.
It's created a whole new
language of creativity.
And more importantly,
there's not a fuckin' soul
under 21 in America that
doesn't live on the platform.
Right, and those 21 year
olds become 27 real quick.
And so it's the only thing
I've seen since Facebook
where I know the 19 year old
is going to be 26 and still on it.
And that's why I'm so bullish on it.
- [Voiceover] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(applause)
- [Voiceover] Fuck yeah, I'm all in.
- Yes you are, Simon.
- [Voiceover] Say my name bitch.
- Be careful Simon.
- [Voiceover] I came here with my aunt
and this presentation had been announced
and based on South by Southwest.
Four people in this room
just said you gotta come here
at different times this morning.
I cut the queue to meet one of them
and then the other one said, there's Gary,
as we were going in.
So I'm like, what'd I say?
- You said, great keynote,
before I gave the talk.
- [Voiceover] And then you
said, thanks for coming Simon.
- Yes I did.
- [Voiceover] That just
blew my fuckin' mind.
- Thank you mate.
- [Voiceover] So I just want
to a one on one conversation.
- Let's do it.
- [Voiceover] Notting Hill,
did you see Notting Hill?
- No.
- [Voiceover] Oh, it's
like Julia Roberts and.
- Is this a romantic situation now?
- [Voiceover] No.
- OK,cause I was excited.
- [Voiceover] It is a good movie though.
- That's what I thought.
- [Voiceover] I'm glad you're excited.
- OK, let's go.
- [Voiceover] It's Julia Roberts.
- Yes I wanna be, OK, good.
- [Voiceover] And I'll do Brad.
- Let's do it.
- [Voiceover] Right,
and all the world's media there at the end
and he tells her.
- That he loves her?
- [Voiceover] Cause she's just
a girl and he's just a boy.
- Right, and the good
news is I am just a girl.
- [Voiceover] We're
gonna get to that later.
- OK.
- [Voiceover] I didn't
deliver it I'm afraid.
- No worries, I'm following,
believe it or not.
- [Voiceover] OK, so you
shared a story with me.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] Like I'd
been to a lot of events.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] A lot of industries and
you're like, off to another path.
- Thank you.
- [Voiceover] I'm gonna
share a story about my life.
- Please.
- [Voiceover] Picture Kilkeel,
it's a fishing village
in Ireland right near the
border on the east coast.
- I'm picturing, I think everybody should
close their eyes right now.
I'm picturing, go ahead.
- [Voiceover] And it's 1878.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] And there's a potato famine.
- OK.
- [Voiceover] This guy
has to take his family
out of Ireland so they go
to west coast of England.
And they tried farming there
and the mother and the father die.
The two boys who are laborers.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] They're all laborers.
- Yes, I understand.
- [Voiceover] They catch a
fuckin' boat to New Zealand.
They get to New Zealand and they get land.
- How old are the boys?
- [Voiceover] I don't
know, but they're like.
(laughter)
- Simon, that really, that
matters to me in this story.
- [Voiceover] Well I'll
go find out, alright.
- OK, go ahead, go ahead.
- [Voiceover] I was pacing to go myself.
- Understood, keep going.
- [Voiceover] And they get some land.
- How, did they steal it
or did the government give it to them,
it was during some sort of
big opportunity of land grab?
- [Voiceover] Stop interrupting.
- OK, sorry.
(laughter)
I'm just trying to help you
make the story fuckin' better,
Simon.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] I'm trying to talk fast
so I can get through my story quick.
- No worries.
- [Voiceover] Alright,
because this is not
even the fucking story,
I've got another story for you.
- Simon, I've got a news alert.
That ship sailed a long time ago.
Fast is over my man, just own it, go.
- [Voiceover] Alright, fine.
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Ok cool,
so they get some land.
My dad grows up on that farm,
so I think it's his
grandad comes over, right.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] And his mum
encouraged him to read.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] And he
reads and reads and reads
and he doesn't want to get into the farm
- This is your dad.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, he's
born in 1925 on this farm.
- OK.
- [Voiceover] And he ends up,
through reading in 1955
getting a scholarship to Ohio State.
- OK.
- [Voiceover] And he gets his PHD there
and goes back to New Zealand
and he starts a sort of a revolution
in guidance counseling.
- OK.
- [Voiceover] He says to me when I'm 16,
cause I'm like, dad I don't
want to go to university.
I got in my family there's
like there's seven kids
and my parents, there's
nine people including me.
And there's like five PHD's,
there's been like four
or five academic careers.
I don't wanna go the university dad.
In fact, I just wanna do shit I love.
He said, listen,
get your ticket.
I don't care what you do after
this, just get your ticket.
- Yep.
- [Voiceover] Right this
year, get your fuckin' ticket.
So I get my ticket
and then I said, OK, game on right.
He said you show us.
And my last year of high school
I take up drama, I take
up creative writing,
these subjects for the first
time just to shit I'm into.
- Yep.
- [Voiceover] Five years later I'm 23
and I've written for my son and girlfriend
a play telling the story
about Polynesian immigration
into New Zealand because
there's no fuckin'
modern stories for Polynesian's
living in New Zealand.
- OK, makes sense.
- [Voiceover] Well hopefully now.
There is this standing ovation
from this guy who is a top rugby player.
Farm grownup guy
and he just applauds like crazy.
It was the proudest moment of my life.
- Good for you.
- [Voiceover] And so,
just fast forward a few,
just a couple more.
- No worries, I'm with you
man, I am, I'm with you.
I swear.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, yeah, so
in London
I've gone into television
and then I've gone in technology,
I got into the SaaS business.
- OK.
Through my parents introduction to guys
that studied meditation in prison.
Got out of prison, met my
mom, said you inspired me
and the amazing entrepreneur,
this guy Gerald Henry,
you talked about Texas.
This guy Gerald Henry's
such a fuckin' amazing guy.
I'll share a story about him.
He's a banker that came to America.
- Sounds like my kinda guy.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, so he says
you know we should work together
after we come out of meditation.
And then we built a SaaS business.
We launched it on the New
Zealand stock exchange.
We have a million in sales,
it's a market cap of a hundred million.
- Right.
- [Voiceover] In 2007.
- Of course, cause all those Wall Street
and markets are full of shit.
- [Voiceover] Right and then
it just got bought last week.
Just got bought by a
private equity firm Villion.
- Mazel tov.
- [Voiceover] I was in
sales and it killed me.
I was making, I made like a
million a year at one point
and I just had to go no.
Cause I was doing what you're saying.
I did it, it was killing us,
it was the same fuckin'
thing 25 times a week,
- Yep, can believe.
- [Voiceover] It was just killing me.
So I said I've gotta go.
And I met a guy at a funeral.
(drowned out by laughter)
- Aye aye, baby.
- [Voiceover] I'll never see that again.
And his brother in law had just died.
(laughter)
And we start sharing stories
about us just like this, right.
- Yep.
- I told Gerald that now, if
we need to talk to this guy.
We raised 50 million for the company.
We listed on the stock
exchange in two years
at 100 million.
I just got kicked out of the company
like two weeks ago.
- Sorry to hear that.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, that's fine.
(laughter)
You know why that's fine?
Because they're so full of shitness
in their company, right.
- No kidding.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Part of the
problem is that Gerald
is a master storyteller who's
a master business leader.
- Is selling something fake?
- [Voiceover] Well now he can't be in it
cause he's the crook.
- I understand.
- [Voiceover] Now he's the crook because.
- You need to hook up with the kid
that loves the drug dealers.
(laughter)
Simon, listen, only because I wanna
be kind to the people behind you.
I could do this forever.
- [Voiceover] So here's
my, I love you man.
- Thank you man, I love you back.
Let's clap it up for
this man, get over here.
(applause)
Thanks for getting it,
thanks for getting it.
Thanks for getting it.
How you gonna top that man?
- [Voiceover] Hi Gary, my name is Ricardo.
- Ricardo.
- [Voiceover] I'm
from Sao Paulo, Brazil.
- Pleasure to see.
- [Voiceover] You have
a lot of fans in Brazil.
- Thank you.
- [Voiceover] And I love you.
- I love you too.
- [Voiceover] Because you
smell of authenticity.
- Thank you.
- [Voiceover] You know.
- Thank you so much man.
- [Voiceover] This is
my seventh time here.
You are the first guy that I saw here
in seven years in a row.
And stand up, you know,
outside the room to.
- To say hello.
- [Voiceover] To interact with everybody.
So that's why I love you.
- Thank you man.
(applause)
It's, you know why, you
know why you love me?
Cause I loved you first.
I'm not joking by the way.
The reason you love your parents so much
is they loved you first.
This is a stunningly important thing.
Your example to why you love me
was cause I loved you
first and it wasn't a joke.
It's actually something
very important to me.
My optimism is an absolute
fuel to my energy.
I am so bullish on people.
Like we've been around a long time now.
We've had a lot of capabilities
for that to not be the case.
I know I'm getting a little
heady here but we are.
I'm so sad that mainstream
media took control
over the 70, 80 year period that
we just came out of and only talked about
the .00001% of us that are shit.
And it's our own fault,
we love to rubberneck.
And that's why they kept feeding us.
But I am, there is no brand in the world
that is more underrated than us.
I'm all about team human.
And people get mad at me that
I'm like fuck dogs and fuck trees
and I know it's not super popular
but I'm telling you right now,
I'll kill a fuckin' dog for
a person any day of the week.
I am big fan of humans.
(applause)
Don't tweet I'll kill a dog
out of context, out of context.
Don't be mean.
Make the context, make the context.
Go ahead, my man.
- [Voiceover] Well my question
is you are very authentic.
But the business world
not so many, not so much.
- That's my opportunity my man.
- [Voiceover] Let's make
the situation where you
so if you have to do
away with #AskGaryVee Show
and you have to go
and work for Coca-Cola.
- Won't happen, won't happen.
I can't even, I can't.
You're better off saying make pretend
you turned into a fuckin' dragon.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] But the question
is I'm asking you is because
maybe some people here or
myself, works in a place,
wears suits and meetings.
- Leave.
- [Voiceover] Not yet, that's it?
- Yeah.
Here's why, here, let's fix.
- [Voiceover] Let's say
I don't wanna leave.
- Let's start over, let's
start over, let's start over.
- [Voiceover] Let's say
that I don't wanna leave.
- Let's start with why
you don't wanna leave.
You like your car.
- [Voiceover] My father's company.
- Well.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] What advice do
you give to some people here,
some people here that can't, can't.
I don't know they are.
- Here's, here's, ready for this.
That's right, they have
college debt, they have this.
Look, here's my advice
my man and thank you.
I really enjoy this question.
- [Voiceover] And they want
to turn the place they work
into authenticity place.
- You have to go tell your
fuckin' dad that you need
to fire the cancer, no
matter how much they earn,
no matter how good they are.
If they're the number one
earner, the single best driver
of your business you need to fire them
because they're killing
it from the inside.
(applause)
That's number one.
For everybody else, for everybody else
look, I'm not some great philosopher.
This is simple shit.
One at bat, that's it.
You're gonna die.
Like I don't understand.
Here's what I don't understand.
And this is a very good, thank you so much
cause this is actually the
next thing I'm gonna wanna
talk about after I'm done
with this whole thing.
I wanna talk about complaining.
I want to talk about complaining.
If you were making your bed
that you have to sleep in it,
and you need to shut your
fuckin' mouth, right.
You are more than welcome.
I've met hundreds of people
that have left their jobs
making good money, when
they had college debt,
18% compounded interest
because they needed their
mental health to be happy.
And they were willing to take a step back
and in a seven year period they won
cause happiness drives everything.
You collectively are not patient enough.
Your lack of patience is killing you.
And your need of things is killing you.
You don't need a fuckin' watch,
you don't need a fuckin' whip.
You need to be happy.
One fuckin' at bat.
Go spend more time with
80 and 90 year olds.
You know what,
and I think three of you will do this,
this is why I"m giving this advice.
Go do something I did a long time ago
when I was charting my thing.
Why don't you go do some public service
and go to a nursing home and help.
I'm asking you to do this by the way.
Go spend three times,
four hours of your life.
Go there to be selfish for you,
not because you're a nice
person, you're helping.
I went cause I was selfish.
I wanted to go fuck with
people that lived it.
I wanted to hear what
the common themes were.
And there's only happy
people and unhappy people
and the only thing was
did they do what they
wanted to do versus not.
I'm the happiest because I'm
doing exactly what I wanna do.
You'll not hear me publicly complain ever
or privately that I miss my kids.
That's my choice, I'm
working hard, too hard.
So I don't have the audacity
to complain about it.
You're more than welcome to
leave your dad's company.
You're more than welcome
to leave Coca-Cola.
You've got other things but
you're caught up in the machine.
Get the fuck out of the
machine for a second
and think about what you're doing here.
You're gonna die, you get
one chance, you got so lucky.
You know the math behind
being a human being.
Every person in here
fuckin' won the lotto.
You won, you're a fuckin' person.
Not a ladybug, not a tire,
not this mic, this guy, you suck.
So listen, it's hard.
I left my dad's business,
not so easy, right.
But you're in control of your life.
And so there's only two
conversations for you.
You go and tell pops,
this guy Javier needs to get
the fuck out out of here.
I don't give a shit that
he's fuckin' killin' it.
Nobody likes him, he's
cancer and he's selfish
and yes he's growing our
business but he's gotta go.
Or dad, Javier's gotta go.
No son, he's not, he's winning.
Cool, see you pops.
That's it, that's it.
(applause)
That's it.
Alright, rapid fire time,
I promised em I'd go offstage on time.
- [Voiceover] Hi Gary.
- Hello.
- [Voiceover] I'm gonna speak slowly now.
- Good.
- [Voiceover] My name is Iscander.
I go by Iroc when on Twitter.
I was born and raised in
the former Soviet Union.
I graduated from UC Berkeley,
did research at MIT.
Over the past few month I've been getting,
I've been getting flooded
by emails from you.
I didn't know what you did,
but I sure wanted you to sell my product.
I'm gonna tell, I'm
gonna give you a story.
So I'm running a company.
(booing and laughter)
- I got a good favor that
we're both gonna win.
Why don't you come after the talk
and I'll talk to you one on one.
This way we can get a couple more people.
- [Voiceover] It's gonna
be shorted than expected.
- Well good, stop booing, go.
- [Voiceover] OK, so I'm
running a company that builds
every third camera in the world
plus Sony and Nikon.
- OK.
- [Voicieover] We're putting
50 human years into our SDK
and now we're putting our
expertise into 360 videos.
Not just another 360 video camera.
Completely different approach.
Wearable miniature ergonomic.
- Great.
- [Voiceover] So, and the
best part about it is, we are.
- Let's assume I think it's
the greatest thing of all time.
Are you interested in me investing
or are you interested in me
helping you get to somebody?
- [Voiceover] I'm interested
in you in joining the team.
- That's impossible because I'm too busy.
- [Voiceover] Alright, I get that.
- Yep.
- [Voiceover] So basically.
(drowned out by laughter)
- Let me, do me a favor,
cause I really want to be
fair to the collective.
I'll literally talk to you one on one.
It's better than this.
Just hang over there.
Next.
(applause)
Thanks for coming.
My man.
- [Voiceover] Hello Gary.
- Hello.
- [Voiceover] Big fan,
been a big fan for awhile.
- Awesome.
- [Voiceover] I am the
founder of my own small
outdoor recreation business.
It's kinda like the Tom's
Shoes of camping hammocks.
- You sure it's not the uber of.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Not the uber, no.
- Go ahead.
- [Voiceover] A question I had for you is,
you're so outgoing with your brand
and you are really the face of it.
Do you think that's
important for a start up
to have someone who is
marketing their brand?
- No.
- [Voiceover] No, thank you.
- I think that if you build
the best fucking whatever, you win.
- [Voiceover] Awesome, thank you.
- You're welcome.
(applause)
Fuck, I promised.
Yeah.
- [Voiceover] My name is Ethan Simonton,
habitstacker.com, I build
habits through experiments
living on the street, not
eating, those types of things.
- Interesting.
- [Voiceover] I totally agree with you
not enough of us are hustling.
We're complaining too much.
- Yep.
- [Voiceover] We're not
doing the fuckin' work.
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] So I also
know you believe that
entrepreneurs are born and not made.
- I believe big time, all
time, great entrepreneurs
that build million dollar companies
have to have that DNA to go there.
I believe everybody here can be
the best version of an entrepreneur
but that might be a
$200,000 a year business
because you weren't gifted with
Lebron's skills or Beyonce's.
I think it is a skill, yes, keep going.
- [Voiceover] Now, so
my question for you is
can you hustle your way
to being an entrepreneur?
- No but you can hustle your way
instead of making an
$83,000 a year business
to a $337.000 a year business.
Hard work is the single variable
that can extenuate.
Also, there's a lot of people
in this room that were born
with body types that I
would even look better
for the two years worth of
work that I put in, or worse.
Like we can't discount
DNA in entrepreneur-land
cause it's not convenient.
Some of you aren't good enough
but you'd be unbelievable
number threes and sevens.
The number 19 guy,
the number 27 girl at Facebook
made the right decision to
not start their company.
Got it?
Like we are not deploying
enough self awareness
but hard work is the variable
to maximize your success.
Thank you.
(applause)
I gotta go right?
I really do right, like
there's no kind of like,
there's no like gangster
like you have a lunch thing
and I can still do it,
there's just like yeah.
- [Voiceover] A couple more questions.
- No, they're really,
they're pretty aggressive.
I love you.
Real quick.
I wanna do some sort of weird contest.
- [Voiceover] Take a selfie.
- Right now?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, you with
everybody behind you man.
Have everybody go up
there and take a selfie
with everyone behind you.
- She's bringin' it.
I'm definitely not doing that
because I like to fight the system.
I love you, see ya.
(applause)
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Thanks for being here.
Here.